uh we we do have a new secretary of the
interior
did you see that all right i have a
question though sure is it a woman
yes thank god but not just a woman
a native american woman
a former congresswoman from new mexico
called deb holland
is joe biden's incoming secretary of the
interior and that's not a small job make
fun of it if you will but the interior
department manages about a fifth
of the entire surface area of the united
states it's got 70
000 employees and an enormous budget so
it's a lot of power to run it what does
deb holland plan to do with all this new
power
well no one's asked her they're too busy
celebrating what she looks like
congresswoman dab holland appearing
before senators for her confirmation
hearing today
she would make history as the first
native american cabinet secretary if she
is confirmed
she would be the first native american
cabinet secretary if confirmed she is a
historic pick in this respect
she is amazing remember when they used
to go like
uh so-and-so is going to be named
uh secretary of defense that's it he
comes to us uh
after 25 years in the navy where he
served on the uss
you know [ __ ] and uh you know
fought in three foreign wars and won
this bronze star
for his heroic blah blah blah remember
you used to do that and then they go
then he went off to uh officer school
and did this and that
no nowadays it's like oh my god she's
huh how cool and you're like so that was
no other because i wouldn't even care if
you were like hey you know diversity is
good
we gotta we got you know it's cool to
see some women and well i don't think so
it's cool to see some women in the white
house or
native american or whatever fine but
could you at least add a couple of
qualifications like
hey she's native ameri first native
american ever that's kind of cool also
she went to this school and uh you know
in her last uh
in her last job in the government she
oversaw this and you could go oh
okay but everything is just that's a
woman
can't attack a woman bro he's going to
be the first native american to serve in
this role
the interior department of course
governs public lands tribal lands
and so this is going to be a very uh
exciting pick for many democrats we
could make her secretary of fireworks
no we couldn't or alcoholism democrats
it's very exciting that deb holland is a
native american that's cnn's position
they don't explain why it's exciting but
it's a good question why is it exciting
none of us choose how we were born it's
nothing that we did or that we earned
so it seems a little weird to be quote
excited about an
accident of birth how excited would cnn
be if deb holland were unusually tall or
had red hair
was born left-handed the good news for
deb holland is since she was born the
way that she was
no one is allowed to criticize her as
that's true
well they're desperate to launch a
counter-attack against
the democratic president at this point
attacking any old thing will do
but because you guys never attack the
republican president you guys
did you guys were distinguished and you
guys get the republican president
they're supposed to attack him they
literally attack
like roofers and like guys who do
sheetrock and people like they dox
teenagers and they you know what i mean
like it's beyond just hey we don't like
this president it's like
hey this guy this kid 17 year old let's
get him kicked out of his high school
because he made a meme like you know
it's they take it to such a nasty level
we're also talking about republicans
here
so the go-to is the same go to as usual
pick out the women and the people of
color and just go off
that's what they do that's exactly what
they do they do you're right
you're right you guys don't pick on
white people uh for for farting in the
wrong direction you guys are literally
going after cartoons right now
you're going after cartoons and you're
talking about
questioning someone who's gonna be in
the department of interior i mean
there's a difference here guys it's been
my observation
given the last four to five years of
anti-white sentiment and people getting
[ __ ] on just for being white men
that if there's anything i've learned is
that
white people are infinitely patient
and and graceful i don't even know how
we we still live in this reality where
the news is like and these white people
are going around just killing everybody
and meanwhile you're like
i don't see it i don't see that i just
see you guys sparking about white people
all day
and making charts and making entire
books about
gay like the spectrum of whiteness and
and like
literally it's it's now a cottage
industry of just hating white people
and i haven't seen any other than a
couple of dopey [ __ ]
uh um rushing a guardrail and going into
the capitol building
i haven't seen much uh although they did
brutally murder that that poor capital
police officer with the fire
extinguisher
it didn't happen you don't remember they
did so dude
i saw it baked alaska nick fuentes and
vincent james
took turns wailing on that poor cop with
extinguisher until he was dead i
personally think it's a hate crime
uh this is well i'm we're gonna finish
this video but i have this just breaking
news
uh
the biden administration has the biden
administration is just a
has a at a new department that's never
been added before
uh to his cabinet and its department of
offensive cartoons
and this is the guy that was going to be
taking the lead
not judge doom it's judge doom we can't
come
he literally murders tunes well i don't
know what to tell you you can't
criticize him though do you remember
what he did to that poor shoe
yeah he did didn't you feel bad for that
[ __ ] it felt very bad that poor shoe was
so cute
that was such a brutal scene i'm like oh
there's a kid's movie yeah
yeah uh so yes that will be the person
that'll be
heading that up so let's see here
back to joy rage and so several
republicans have decided to target
biden's cabinet nominees of color like
deb holland
so that's who deb holland is she's a
person of color the most important thing
about deb holland is her ethnicity
that's the unanimous message from our
professional class but since we're
playing identity politics here which
obviously is disgusting we wish we
weren't identity politics is stupid and
immoral but since we are
it's fair to ask a few more questions
deb holland identifies as a native
american
on the other hand holland sounds very
much like a scandinavian name and that
stuck out to some of us who have
scandinavian names so what's going on
here
well in fact deb holland is every bit as
much scandinavian as she is
american indian her father was norwegian
when my ancestors came here and brought
slave ships to america
to transport your slaves
we thought we were buying into the
system
and that means in addition to everything
else deb holland is america's
first norwegian american interior
secretary since thomas cleppy
served in the ford administration almost
50 years
such an [ __ ] you really are a [ __ ]
nerd and i love you
you know what tucker reminds me of like
he makes me think of like
what dennis miller could have been if he
was funny
yeah yeah there you go good point it's
like a funny dennis miller
in their quiet brooding way the
scandinavian former
secretary of interior thomas clippy babe
who knows that who knows that reference
to go in their quiet brooding way the
scandinavian community we can tell you
is beaming with pride finally one of
ours has made it
one of ours little girls with names like
larson and hanson and doll
will watch cabinet meetings on c-span
and know that they too
have a chance to oversee one-fifth of
the american land mass someday
when deb holland speaks she'll be
speaking for millions of norwegian
americans
people whose ancestors have been here in
the americas for more than a thousand
years
their voices can now be heard deb
holland hero to the nordic people
when my people came here on wooden boats
with horned helmets
i mean at least change your name like de
blasio is she our guy
she's nordic is she is she sure gal i
mean i do love the fact that like these
people
of color in these leadership positions
are all just
white people oh yeah of course black
lives matter is run entirely by jewish
people
like these cabinet positions everyone's
like i'm an indian black woman and
you're like
she's like 60 white yeah i don't know
what you're talking about
i think you only have to be at least in
the tri i can't speak for all the tribes
like to get they think like the casino
money here
you only have to be one
[Music]
fifth i believe one get that seven money
one fifth
yeah i wanna [ __ ] i want to can they
can todd howard if when you remake
skyrim again which you will
can you make the graybeards all native
americans you go to see them and they
all turquoise jewelry on
native americans the dragonborn must
fight the dragon
come on by using this and you're like oh
do you teach me dragon shouts
no we have carved you these special
arrowheads that's it it's great
and a turquoise ring oh is it magic
though right i get to
gives me powers no we sell them at rest
areas and truck stops
are they at least dragonbone arrows no
but the money goes to the tribe oh
that's great
you know native americans don't have to
pay this is true don't have to pay sales
tax
for real if you're like one-fifth so if
you go to arrest like a native american
in florida because we have a lot of them
here
in florida if you're native american you
go to a restaurant
you show them your native american and
they have to take the sales tax off of
your bill
i'm doing that from now on you need an
actual
card that shows that you are or what if
i just start doing an annoying rain
dance in front of a full restaurant
until they go all right
just it's percent just give it to him
they'll give you the maggiano's
treatment let's look at the native
american section
just sitting there with a stick in my
head
[Music]
like just can you give it to him man we
got a [ __ ] 30 top coming in
of black people that we got to put in
the back
were they where they belong as
maggiano's i believe was quoted as
saying
sir this is a wawa okay and there's a
line around the block right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah can i get a manager
please
to register to well well there's a bunch
of
well there's a bunch of mexican roofers
just waiting like
this [ __ ] man and they're
definitely more native than anything
else you have aztec blood in them and
they have to [ __ ] sit there
and they're like just it's eight percent
dude just give it to him get him the
[ __ ] out of here